We committed to work hard together to do so.
We knew that for us to be able
to make the most of the potential of our partnership,
solutions were needed
for the issues around the protocol on Island
Northern Ireland.
We knew it was not going to be easy.
We knew we needed to listen to each other's concerns
very carefully.
Above all, we had to listen to the concerns
of the people of Northern Ireland.
We knew we had to work hard
with clear minds and determination.
But we also both knew the regime that we could do it
because we were both generally committed
to find a practical solution
for people and for all communities in Northern Ireland.
Today we can take pride in the fact
that we have delivered on that commitment
because today we have agreed, um.
We have reached an agreement in principle
on the Windsor Framework.
The Windsor Framework
lays down new arrangements on Ireland,
Northern Ireland.
This new framework will allow us to begin a new chapter.
The New Windsor Framework
is here to benefit people in Northern Ireland
and support all communities
celebrating peace on the island of Ireland.
And this is why I believe we can now open a new chapter
in our partnership.
A stronger EU UK relationship,
standing as close partners,
shoulder to shoulder,
now and in the future.